c'était le temps des jours heureux pour
tiens bizarre mais le 13 juillet 2016
elle devenait premier ministre du
royaume uni avec les plaques sep
mais diriger un pays qui vient de voter
en faveur de la séparation avec l'union
européenne n'aura pas été facile
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
entre deux petits pas de deux théories
ça mais on aura beau tenter de faire
entrer dans la danse du brds excite de
membres de son propre parti
elle aurait été incapable de mener à
bien la sortie britannique de l'europe
sa démission qui est devenue effective
aujourd'hui donc officiellement le coup
d'envoi de la campagne la direction du
parti conservateur et par ricochet c'est
aussi la campagne pour le choix de la
personne qui lui succédera à l'acte est
du pays
parmi les onze candidats il y à boris
johnson de favori ancien maire de
londres et ex-ministre des affaires
étrangères
il vient d'obtenir le rejet des
poursuites pour ses mensonges présumés
liés au référendum sur le break site
mais comment sera désigné le prochain
premier ministre
parmi ces neuf hommes et ces deux femmes
pour entrer dans la course
chacun devra obtenir l'appui de huit
députés ensuite après une série de vote
secret tenu par les députés
conservateurs
il ne restera que deux candidats qui
seront alors départagées par les membres
du parti conservateur qui voteront par
la poste
le ou la locataire du 10 downing street
sera désigné le 22 juillet prochain
même problème reviendra sur la table
comment négocier le break site d'ici le
31 octobre la date limite est sur ce
sujet difficile de départager les
actuels candidats n'arrivent à rim les
politiques suspects week end
car selon ce politologue les successeurs
potentiels n'en parle pas trop pour
l'instant
en attendant le choix du 22 juillet
prochain celui sommeil va assurer
l'intendance d'un pays qui n'est pas au
bout de ses peines ici frédéric arnould
radio canada montréal